we are lost in the timestream catching
up on 50 years of TV for our upcoming
Doctor Who honest trailer but don't get
too wibbly-wobbly who viens to tide you
over here's a supercut featuring the
doctor's most famous arch enemies
thought this act on his trailers will
return next week and be on the lookout
for our Doctor Who trailer coming this
October okay so what are you must be a
secret government project extrapolating
the DNA of a time traveler what happens
to Homer Simpson in the future
[Music]
[Applause]
by unfolding believable Wow whoo okay if
my aunt asks would you care for some tea
a Dalek race
no but my ship survived
why are you here
[Music]
cabinets are how come on yeah well not
escape really I retire for what like
five minutes it all goes
beautiful does it surprise you to know
that is why we have never been
[Music]
the spell I just feel you